هنا نذهب في هذه السيارة الكهربائية لا تستطيع A Lead
Foot الوصول إليك إلا حتى الآن ، فهي
مجهزة بمساعدة السرعة الذكية
مما يعني أن السيارة تعرف أن
الحد الأقصى للسرعة هنا هو 20 ميلاً في
الساعة ولن يسمح لك بالذهاب فوقها
لذلك أنا  الضغط على الدواسة ولكنك ترى في
الواقع أن
الشيء الذي يقودني هو نائب عمدة مدينة نيويورك
ميرا جوشي ، المدينة هي الأولى
في الولايات المتحدة التي جربت تقنية محدد السرعة
في 50 من مركبات أسطولها
التي نحتاج إلى أن نكون في المقدمة ،
لا يوجد سبب اليوم مع  الكثير من التكنولوجيا
والوعي بأن أي شخص
يجب أن يموت على يد سيارة
تُظهر البيانات الفيدرالية أن أكثر من 20 ألف
حالة وفاة على طرقنا في النصف الأول من
هذا العام هو أحد الأسباب التي جعلت مجلس سلامة النقل الوطني في
أحدث توصياته المتعلقة بالسلامة
يدعو الحكومة الفيدرالية
لبدء تحفيز صانعي السيارات
لوضع أنظمة تحديد السرعة في السيارات الجديدة
علينا أن نتذكر أن هذه ليست مجرد
أرقام ، فهؤلاء أشخاص فقدوا
حياتهم في نيويورك  يعمل برنامج محدد السرعة من
خلال شيء يسمى
البيانات المخزنة عن بُعد على حدود السرعة المحلية
ويتم الرجوع إليها مع
برنامج تحديد المواقع GPS للسيارة في سيارات نيويورك
يعطي السائق إنذارًا
أو ببساطة يقطع المسرع
عندما تصل إلى الحد الأقصى للسرعة
يطلق عليه  الدواسة الميتة لهذا النظام
يمكن تجاوزها إذا ضغطت على هذا
الزر ، يمكنك التسريع إلى ما بعد
الحد الأقصى للسرعة لمدة 15 ثانية في حال
احتجت إلى الدمج أو الإسراع لتلبية
تدفق حركة المرور إذا كان شخص ما في
المسار السريع يقود ببطء شديد ، ثم بالنسبة لي
التي تسببت في وقوع حوادث أكثر من القيادة
بشكل أسرع ، فهي تبدو نوعًا من التدخل والتدخل ،
أعتقد من
وجهة نظر تنظيمية ، أعتقد أنه قد
يتجاوز بعض الحدود ، أعتقد أن
المستهلك العادي سيرى هذا
باعتباره تجاوزًا من قبل الحكومة في
الصناعة ، خبير الصناعة كارل براور.  سيكون
الأمر متروكًا لصانعي السيارات لتسريع السلامة
دون وضع الفرامل على المبيعات ،
وأعتقد أن خطوة كهذه هي بالتأكيد
علامة على المستقبل.  هذه معاينة
لمناطق الجذب القادمة وربما
لا يمكن تجنب تغيير لا يمكن أن يأتي قريبًا
بما يكفي لخوان بوليتو ، وآمل جدًا
أن يأخذوا الأمر بجدية وأنهم في الواقع
يقومون بإجراء التغييرات
التي قُتلت زوجته وأطفاله على يد سائق مخمور قادم.
حادث تحطم كان بمثابة
مصدر إلهام لـ NTSB الذي يدعو
لأنظمة محدد السرعة ، فإنه سينقذ
الأرواح ، وسيمنع
وقوع المزيد من الحوادث وتقليل
اضطرار العائلات إلى المرور بما أمر به